[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
have a brand new Batman teaser to break
down a whole bunch of cryptic stuff
that's been posted in the past couple of
days and a whole bunch of news about the
new Batman trilogy with Matt Reeves we
found out who some of the characters are
going to be because of the Joker movie
the birds of prey movie in the new
Robert Pattinson Batman movie it is the
season of the Batman again this is gonna
be so much new Batman stuff happening
this new teaser is just the beginning of
that will do a new Amazon giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best theory
about what this teaser is for on the
video we'll do Easter eggs for all this
footage first then I'll talk about the
new Batman trilogy with Matt Reeves and
the new characters that they just
announced
so if you don't know what's going on you
don't know what these teasers are for WB
games Montreal was celebrating Batman
day this past weekend by tweeting WB
games Montreal is proud to celebrate
Batman's 80th anniversary with the rest
of the world during Batman day Batman 80
there's a Batman day the DC and Warner
Brothers celebrate every year but this
past year was the 80th anniversary of
the very first appearance of Batman in
Detective Comics so it was a pretty big
deal this tweet from WB games Montreal
was the first time that the account had
tweeted since 2015 though so people were
like wait a minute why is WB Montreal
doing this oh they doing to celebrate
Batman day what they did with in this
suite though is what people were really
talking about because within this 30
second video they interspersed frames
with these special symbols so I'll play
the video here
[Music]
this was this past Saturday this morning
as I'm posting this video they posted a
brand new teaser which highlights those
symbols much more specifically much more
prominently with the caption that reads
capture the night as in the dark night
slash cop sur la nuit which is capture
the night in French French is one of the
main languages at Montreal Quebec so you
could interpret them including this
French translation as being something
like that or you could look at it as
another Easter Egg for these symbols
because one of the symbols is actually a
French Batman symbol decoding the
special symbols from the first teaser
and then the second teaser video the
first one actually represents raesha
cool the demons head symbol the second
one is the French one it's the order of
st. Dumas symbol which is where Azrael
comes from there a French order so
that's probably why they included this
French phrasing in this tweet here and
then the final symbol is the symbol of
the court of owls scott snyder also
tweeted this beware the court of owls so
that seems pretty obvious that the court
of owls is going to be one of the main
villains so all three of these concepts
in these characters appear at various
points in the Arkham games series but
the whole idea is is that the
PlayStation state of play is this week
so it sounds like WB games Montreal is
teasing that they're gonna release a new
Batman game in the next couple of years
there's no actual release date but
typically they try to build on the
success of Batman franchises in the
original game Arkham Asylum was
published after the Dark Knight trilogy
started to blow up with Christopher
Nolan and Christian Bale we have a brand
new Batman franchise coming with Matt
Reeves and Robert Pattinson so it makes
sense that they would want to capitalize
on that again but they were also
probably waiting for the next generation
of consoles to roll around which is why
the game probably won't be released till
late next year or maybe even the year
after that depending on how far along
they are but what this is implying is is
that the main villains of this new game
these three symbols would be racial goal
being the first big boss as well the
avenging angel would probably be the
second or the other people from the
order of st. Dumas and then the third
the final big boss being Lincoln March
in the court of owls
most people are theorizing that the
timeline of this game will fit somewhere
after the events of Arkham Asylum
because there is a post credit scene
that I'll play in a second from that and
they
overlapped too much with Rocksteady's
Arkham games so if you're not sure
what's going on here WB games Montreal
only did one of the Arkham games Arkham
origins which is sort of an add-on
prequel to the Arkham series the main
Batman Arkham games came from Rocksteady
completely different studio who's also
working on a separate game that they
keep teasing but a lot of people think
that's going to be a Superman game or a
Justice League game some sort of
team-based game if you haven't played
the Arkham games then the reason why
this probably isn't taking place forward
in the timeline after the events of
Arkham Knight because that's the most
recent game that's been published is
because the end of that game was meant
to serve as a sort of bookend for the
entire series where he fakes his death
just like he faked his death at the end
of the Dark Knight trilogy remember the
game sort of flow a little bit from the
movies so whatever this new game would
probably feed a little bit from the long
Halloween story that they're doing with
the Robert Pattinson Batman trilogy but
the end of Arkham Knight is supposed to
be the end of the pre-existing Batman
mythos in the beginning of a new
quote-unquote Batman because this scene
here is him looking like he's using fear
toxin but the world thinks that he's
dead so the myth lives on but the man
Bruce wayne/batman was supposed to die
or believed to be dead at the end of
that game so just to be clear this is WB
games Montreal who's doing all this
teasing about a brand new game coming
out it's more likely that their game
would follow their last big game Arkham
origins so this will fit somewhere
between the end of Arkham origins in the
beginning of Arkham Asylum in the
timeline if you don't remember the story
of Arkham origins you don't actually see
Batman becoming Batman for the first
time during that but it is kind of a
Batman year one situation where Arkham
Asylum is closed at the beginning of the
game they propose reopening it by the
end of the game after he captures the
Joker the game is mostly him running
into his big rogues gallery of main
villains for the very first time so you
fight Killer Croc Deathstroke Firefly
Copperhead Deadshot electrocutioner Lady
Shiva and then Bane for the very first
time during this game Batman doesn't
kill people so most of those villains
show up later in the timeline during the
events of Arkham Asylum
Arkham City and then Arkham Knight at
the very end of Arkham origins there's a
post-credits scene teasing a whole bunch
of stuff coming up but it's almost been
seven years since they published the
game that's how long we've had to wait
to find out
comes next after that post-credit scene
good one bats
[Music]
is going to be
figured you'd be by sooner or later
and what happens if I don't sign you rot
in here or you work for me they talk
about reopening Arkham Asylum and then
you see Amanda Waller recruiting
Deathstroke into the Suicide Squad later
throughout the Arkham series in the
timeline Deathstroke pops up you fight
him a bunch so the whole point of this
post-credit scene in those court eval
Easter eggs was just letting you know
that they would be the next big threat
this was coming up we would get this
next part of the story but that was
published back in 2013 it's been forever
since that happened they probably
intended on publishing something sooner
but because of all the turmoil going on
behind the scenes at WB & DC the big
regime changes all the reorganizing of
the way they make Batman movies the new
creative team that's come on they
probably wanted to wait a little bit
till the dust cleared from that and plus
we're getting a new generation of
consoles in the next year at a certain
point they probably just decided that it
was better from a financial perspective
to Bank on the new generation of
consoles the PS 5 and the new version of
the Xbox that's coming up next year
typically when Rocksteady announced
their games they would announce it a
year before release so I wouldn't be
surprised if we do see this game
sometime during the holiday shopping
season next year the only big group of
villains within the Arkham series that
we haven't seen a ton from in the past
is the court of owls
so everybody post your theories about
these teasers in the comments below of
course they'll do giveaways for the game
when it eventually gets here the really
big news just this past day literally
while I was making this video is that
they announced Jeffrey Wright who's
gonna be the watcher for Marvel during
their what-if series he's from West
world you may know him from some other
things is going to be the new
Commissioner Gordon inside Matt Reeves
Batman trilogy with Robert Pattinson
moments ago while I was still working on
this video they also announced that
Jonah Hill was going to be one of the
new villains I think pretty clear he's
probably gonna wind up being penguin he
could also be the Riddler but I really
think that penguin is a better fit for
him there'll be a whole bunch more
Batman stuff happening in the next
couple of weeks and the rest of this
year we have the Joker movie coming up
I'll be posting a bunch of videos for
that then we'll find out who the rest of
the cast is for Matt Reeves Batman films
we'll find out who our new Catwoman is
our new official Riddler and then the
rest of the characters I've already done
a couple videos about the teasers
they've dropped or that in the story
that they've revealed you can click here
for all those Batman teasers and click
here for that brand new Avengers in
Saga trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you